[Music]
just me and you Dave nobody's left not
exactly remember what you taught
me always have a contingency
plan come on
Mac Show
Yourself
I don't know who the kid is Max or if he
means anything to you I took the chance
that he
matters I'll make it simple step out
show yourself and I won't kill the
kid
the wind makes it
interesting side
mirare two more third one goes through
the middle of the
trunk tail
light I was a hair off on that one I
might have hit the
kid
all right time's up
back nice move Mac but it's not going to
make any
difference where are you you son of a
[__]
[__] you
Ma [__] you you could have saved your
life you couldn't save Susan and you're
not going to save this [__] kid is
that in your playbook is that in your
[__] playw show
yourself
a
[Music]
h
no no no
no been
here long time
ago different
life now you come back
yes looking for something
[Laughter]
my
brother you say you can find whatever
you wish in Turkey yeah uhuh how about a
man who kidnapped his own daughter and
took her away from her American
mother an abusive man so not a real man
no love for the child just a
need to punish his ex-wife to take the
one thing away from her that meant
everything to her with no intention of
returning the
child do you think that excuse
me do you think I could find that man in
turkey or
maybe on his way to
Turkey I
uh would not be looking for such a
man it will be
be
dangerous for
you men like him would think that and
God is my witness I would give him a
chance to
stop to
reconsider to think about the worst
thing that could ever happen to him to
imagine
that
something
[Music]
there
they two kinds of pain in this
World pain that
hurts pain that
alters
beon then s
Dixon
you going to get
something Ro the
[Music]
C
seconds 1 1,000 2
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
28 - 9 19
your heart's beaten three times at
normal rate that's because you're losing
so much
blood about 30 seconds body's going to
shut down
down and you're going to
suffocate Elena the girl you beat half
death her life's going to go on yours is
going to end right here on this funky
floor over
$9,800 you should have taken the
money 26 1,000 27
1,000
[Music]
sorry hey Andre doesn't this location
been compromised you got to get all your
[__] out of here you got to truck it all
the [__]
out the [__] I'm going to do that and
who's this [__] piece of [__] pushin
made the call I'm just a new
guy pushin pushin pushkin's [__]
money what the [__] you give a [__]
Andre
huh is that a heck
coock this yeah my Rook B is nice what
is he saying I don't [__] can I see
you oh you want to see my
gun uh uh yes and
no oh [__] all right all right all right
whoa whoa whoa you're so [__] nuts
[__] all right everybody settled now
Frank tells me you're the man Andre yeah
he says your guys are incredibly loyal
toward you they'll do anything you say
so if you tell them to put the guns down
lay down on the floor with their hands
behind their back they'll do that won't
they indulge me Andre tell him to lay
down airport yeah was it somebody's
birthday my
daughter how old is
she she's five
[Music]
guess you don't fly that
often been driving in the opposite
direction of Logan for the last 3
[Music]
minutes
[Applause]
come on let's go to the banana get a
blowing hey officer what the [__] put
the light down what's up I'd like to
report a crime really call 911 come on
let's get out of here [__] that guy yeah
I should have shot that [__]
yeah take it
easy did you get this job I blew the
commissioner why wa city services when I
got two corrupt cops right in front of
me it's that guy this [__] guy yeah
back
[Applause]
up
how'd you get that [__] number wasn't
hard yeah you is this asked the lady
down the street one that had the fire
same thing could happen to you with your
whole [__] family inside you pay like
everybody
else how many
copies one yeah you must have a Death
Wish pal what the the [__] do you want
huh huh those people you took the money
from maybe you should give it
back why would we do that be the best
interest of everyone involved really
yeah well maybe our best interest is to
tie a cinder block around your waist and
throw you in the [__] Mystic huh
let's do that it's a good
idea you're supposed to stand for
something Punk
protect and serve uphold the
law
Justice
remember the [__]
up tomorrow you'll have returned all the
money you extorted from those people
you'll tell them it will never happen
again you do that and this video will
never be
seen don't and a half an hour hour later
you'll watch the uncut version on every
[Music]
news
sh
[Music]
[__]
oh
[Music]
o